the biggest problem we see is boyfriends
explain that what do you mean boyfriends
will meet young girls and they're lonely
it's an isolating business it's hard to
make other girlfriends outside of the
industry it's competitive to have
girlfriends inside of the industry so
they very are they're very susceptible
to fall in love with what we call
suitcase pimps um a guy that will drive
them to set um help them with their
stuff but also wants like half of their
money
and suitcase that's what we call them
that's a good it's a great term because
they hold their bags they hold their
bags that's right right and so they
normally don't have to work but they're
at the girl's disposal but you know
these guys tend to be toxic are they
abusive are they are they financially
just scumbags what are these guys
as an agent your biggest fear was a girl
calling you saying i got a boyfriend
you're like oh my god i'd rather you
have anything right now than a boyfriend
um because normally they're there for
the money grab and some of these guys
will go through 10 12 girls in the
industry like i see guys still to this
day at trade shows and i'm like this
motherfucker's come up is unreal like
he's been hustling girls since 2003 has
never worked a real day in his life gets
to go around and you know hook up with
other girls because she's in the
business so of course she lets him have
sex with anybody he wants there's a
whole open life that comes with it and
then the girl ends up not only
heartbroken but with less money do you
ever go up to the guy i'm like listen
[ __ ] i know what you're up to i
know and i'm lisa ann and i don't take
no [ __ ] from nobody and i know that
you're hanging out with this pretty
little 21 year old right now but let me
tell you something if i hear you being a
bad pimp one more time like right but
it's probably so hard for them to find
men who are okay with this period and
also it's just not
exactly
it's hard for them to be alone do they
just want to be loved yeah i just want
to be loved wait wait i really want to
know what male porn stars are like we
never hear about them but are they
emotionally intelligent would you say
that they're more emotionally
intelligent than most men
i did porn for a little bit
i haven't posted it bang bros
because that's here in florida that's
why i asked no but if you know a contact
let me know we'll talk english
this is fantastic no but i'm really sure
so there's a great myth
right there's a great mix there's a mix
of highly intelligent men that just
realized they could do it because maybe
they met a girl in the business and she
asked him to try it and they realized
they could make a lot of money doing it
and they work out all the time and
they're fit i have a friend christian
who was just on my podcast he does
triathlons all over the world and he
knew that like this industry would allow
him to make gobs of money at a period of
time and then take his mutts off to go
and do other things and then there's
just like the dudes that are dumber than
a box of chocolates and that you're you
think to them like thank thank god you
were gifted with that beautiful penis
because otherwise i know like you
couldn't even make it at walmart like so
there's a there's a baby it's like being
born tall and feeling like you have to
do basketball if you're born with that
kind of song you're like all right i
guess i have to
bye